there's a pretty good piece in
Washington monthly by David Atkins which
reminds us that for all of the bad
that's taking place in the United States
right now it's important not to lose
sight of what's just a simple reality
that twenty Republicans in the Senate
could end the national nightmare that is
Donald Trump and I would actually go
even further 14 Republicans could remove
Donald Trump we talk about Trump as this
national disease this virus that has
infected tens of millions of people with
seemingly overwhelming numbers necessary
to remove in November of twenty twenty
election will we need sixty-two million
votes will we need sixty four will we
need seventy million votes depending on
which states those votes come in to
remove Donald Trump there are actually
some tiny groups of people that could
remove the president if they had a
backbone if they decided that they were
going to do the right thing rather than
the partisan thing so let's first start
with David Atkins piece David Atkins
piece reminds us that quote the most
accountable people in America now are
the Craven Republican elected officials
who have the power to stop this yet
refused to and Atkins goes on to say all
it would take is twenty Republican
senators to say no to say that enough is
enough
to put the interests of the United
States ahead of their temporary partisan
interests it would only take well under
half of the Republican Senate caucus to
do the right thing and Atkins points out
this wouldn't even be that bad for the
Republican Party in the end you get Mike
Pence right it would even cost them it
wouldn't even cost them that much as a
party he writes Democrats are extremely
unlikely to lose the house in 2020 hence
the large number of Republican
retirements the Senate is likely to be
deadlocked getting rid of Trump would
still leave Mike Pence in the White
House with the ability to nominate
extremists Federalist Society judges
David Atkins is completely right but
it's actually even worse it's not just
20 Republicans in the Senate there is an
even smaller group that we could remove
Donald Trump because under the 25th
amendment just fourteen people could
remove a sitting president the 25th
amendment outlines a process for
removing a president who is either
unable or unfit
to serve section 4 of the 25th amendment
allows the vice president and a majority
of the cabinet to remove the president
from office under that fourth section it
would take 14 people to remove Donald
Trump vice president Mike Pence and 13
of the 24 cabinet members section 4
reads will put it up on the screen
whenever the vice president and a
majority of either the principal
officers of the executive departments or
of such other body as Congress may by
law provide transmit to the president
pro tempore of the Senate and the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
their written declaration that the
president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of his office
the vice president shall immediately
assumed the powers and duties of the
office as acting president this is a
very quick and simple process in a sense
consider the immorality of being able to
end this national nightmare among a
group of just 20 Republicans in the
Senate among a group of 14 Republicans
in the cabinet including Mike Pence and
choosing not to do it this is the virus
of political partisanship and cronyism
that we've been talking about will I
talked earlier in the show we just need
for Republicans to say let's subpoena
john bolton for republicans in the
senate and then we can do it that gets
us a simple majority we will be
hard-pressed to find four Republican
senators who are willing just to do the
very milquetoast uncontroversial thing
of subpoenaing john bolton to testify in
Donald Trump's impeachment trial
forget about 14 Republicans in the
cabinet or 20 Republicans in the Senate
but my bet if I were to bet is they go
down with the ship or try to outlast
this there is ZERO indication that any
of these people want to be a part of the
solution or that they even really agree
about what the solution is good luck
finding 20 Republicans with a conscience
let alone Republican senators you would
have better luck getting a Santa the
Tooth Fairy and the Easter Bunny to
remove Donald Trump in
20 then you would finding 20 Republican
senators or 14 Republican cabinet
members to make it a reality we're going
to have to do it without them and I can
you know it when I said this a year and
a half ago it felt like maybe it wasn't
the case a year and a half ago I was
saying Trump clearly should be impeached
Trump clearly should be removed under
the 25th amendment something seems
cognitively wrong something is very
wrong in terms of the degree of
corruption that this guy is
participating in but a year and a half
ago I was saying I still believe the
Moller report isn't going to do it
impeachment isn't going to do it
November of 2020 is very quickly going
to become the first soonest and best
opportunity to remove the guy we're now
only just under you know 10 10 months -
a week away from the November of 2020
election it is becoming clearer and
clearer that that is the quickest most
efficient and most direct way to remove
the guy I hope we recognize that I hope
we don't allow the activism that so many
people have participated in since Donald
Trump was first elected to kind of fade
and the enthusiasm to wane we've got to
remember the opportunity is coming up
it's less than 10 months away